hola soy sal de khan academy cuando
escuché la palabra meditación quizás
pueda sonar te como algo de la nueva era
que nada tiene que ver con exámenes
estandarizados y si estás a punto de
presentar un examen estandarizado estoy
seguro de que por tu mente pasan muchos
pensamientos como estoy preparado me va
a ir bien espero no reprobar ese estrés
y esa ansiedad en todo caso van a minar
su desempeño en eso que quieres hacer
bien por eso la meditación es una forma
de ayudar a tranquilizarte pero
realmente sólo tú puedes observar tus
pensamientos nuestras artes y tu mente
empieza a deambular sino regresarla y
tratar de no pensar o pensar solo en
cosas positivas
creo que si haces eso vas a darte cuenta
de que estarás más feliz más positivo
vas a traer todo tipo de energía
positiva y aún cuando no es lo más
importante del mundo te va a ir muy bien
en esos exámenes que te preocupan
ahora